I unfortunately have two different acts
of terror from over the weekend to talk
to you about uh both incidents different
but in some ways raise similar concerns
let's start with the first one a
shooting at fort lauderdale airport in
Florida on Friday just before 1 p.m.
local time near the baggage claim in
terminal to the suspect traveled from
Anchorage Alaska to Florida and had a
legal identified and checked gun in his
luggage specifically a 9-millimeter
semi-automatic handgun which he used for
the shooting after getting his suitcase
from the baggage claim five people were
killed 6 taken to the hospital 30 to 40
others injured but not taken to the
hospital and of course as often happens
whenever there is any incident at an
airport about ten thousand passengers
stranded the suspect was not killed
reportedly arrested without incident and
without any shots fired by law
enforcement the airport closed for the
rest of the day reopen the next morning
this entire incident that left five dead
six wounded and 30 to 40 others injured
to some degree lasted reportedly 70 to
80 seconds and the suspect in custody is
26 year old military veteran Esteban
Santiago Ruiz who was born in New Jersey
served in the Iraq war as a combat
engineer out later served in the Alaska
National Guard and according to his
family members he had become mentally
unstable after his tour in Iraq had
recently received a psychological
evaluation and treatment following a
number of incidents and indeed federal
officials have confirmed it that he was
undergoing treatment for mental health
problems that will be a key part of the
analysis coming up in January of 2016
Santiago was arrested and charged with
assault in an incident involving his
girlfriend in Anchorage Alaska of the
criminal complaint uh shows police
saying that Santiago had attempted to
strangle her and officials also said
that Santiago visited
the FBI field office in Anchorage in
November after that this is just two
months ago after reportedly hearing
voices in his head saying that he should
be committing acts of violence and he
said that on the one hand he was in
control and didn't intend to hurt anyone
but at the same time he claimed that the
US government was controlling his mind
and making him watch videos by the
Islamic State of Iraq and the Levant so
some serious red flags here Pat yes and
apparently about an hour or so after the
shooting took place there were rumors of
another shooter at a different terminal
yeah and that's what actually caused
people to start rushing to the tarmacs
to Stampede out of the airport and for
it to be closed down so it's an
interesting look at human behavior and
the effectiveness of terrorism in that
way so a lot of the video we saw of the
people out on the tarmac was not related
to the 72nd incident in terminal two but
rather a follow-up fear of an incident
in another terminal that's exactly right
there are rumors being spread on social
media that there was a second gunman and
that's what caused people to react so
there's a few discussion points here all
very important number one is the
discussion that is a background of most
of these mass shooting incidents which
is that of mental illness and we have
here numerous interactions with
individuals who called into question uh
the shooters mental health and stability
and clearly the right help was not
ultimately provided now whose fault that
is and where the blame lies for that as
a more complex question in something we
could look at but there's another issue
here which which has to be discussed
which is the firearm angle there is a
gun story here because this is an
individual who by all accounts had to
use it a term loosely not a technical
term had lost his mind but not his
ability to own a gun numerous instances
of interactions with individuals who
should have been able to say because of
them this man's mental state he should
not be allowed to have guns at this time
legislative options exist to to give law
enforcement and concern family members
and mental health professionals the
ability to take guns away because of
acute mental illness situations califor
and Washington State have enacted such
laws to temporarily remove temporarily
firearms from people uh we have data
from Connecticut which has a similar law
which says that these policies are quite
effective so there is a gun story here
as well isn't there and you know it's
gonna be set on the other side to that
uh you're just trying to prevent the
most recent terrorist attack in that
you're taking away his second Amendment
rights without due process right well of
course if we have a law which says this
is not uh did these are interventions
which are allowed because of acute
mental health conditions there are a
number of these uh which which don't
just relate to guns uh ways in which we
have uh enabled certain agencies or
individuals are professionals to say
temporarily until we can sort out to
take a turn from Donald Trump what the
hell is going on we are going to do X Y
or Z in the temporary temporary removal
of guns when there is a concern like
this going on is absolutely important
number three there's the ISIS Muslim
story and in this particular case we
have some online who who are saying well
here we clearly have a Muslim extremists
who was uh essentially influenced by
Isis everybody who watches this show
knows I have no problem saying that if
that's what I believe I don't I don't
know that that's the case here this is
an individual who believed that it was
actually the government by showing him
Isis propaganda that was getting into
his head and causing this instability uh
if if you will be you know if you're
convinced that that was some kind of
cover and that really this is just an
Isis dude this seems like a seriously
mentally ill person I am NOT in the in
the game of saying oh when it's X its
Isis and when it's why it's just mental
illness you know if you watch my show
that that's not what I'm doing I don't
see the primary lens here as being the
lens of radical Islam although I'm open
to having my mind change this seems like
a seriously disturbed person last thing
on this just the other day as part of an
anti-defamation league program that i'm
participating in I was briefed along
with a group of others by a terrorism
and security expert and specifically
this issue of outside of
security terrorism at airports was
mentioned domestic flights in at many
domestic flights uh people who have not
been screened unscreened passengers are
allowed into the baggage claim area and
additionally we know about the risks
that exist when people can bring
whatever they want up to the point of
the security line and this is why Tel
Aviv Airport starts with a security
perimeter I don't know if it's a you
know a half mile or two miles outside of
Ben Gurion Airport but when I was going
to the airport to fly out from Tel Aviv
we were stopped uh and someone comes up
and someone who is trained in in
behavioral observation and looking not
for whether you have a hundred and ten
or ninety milliliters of contact lens
solution but examining behaviorally
asked to open the trunk looked under the
car with a mirror you are starting this
process in concentric circles far away
from the terminal and this this requires
a complete change to webbing TSA is not
exactly going to be able to do this
approach are they yeah when we think of
TSA they're going to screen people more
so based on how they look rather than
how they act and it's good to see that
at least countries like Israel are
taking charge in making it more about
behavior thanks for watching this video
before you watch the next one remember
we're raising money to expand the david
pakman show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated